hello everyone and a special cheerio to
all you old chaps out there welcome to
versus this is my show
i know you hello annabelle hey little
girl i'm mark ellis and in this safe
space we take fine art and make it
competitive you know for funsies this is
a very strange reality to be faced with
in the past we've had duels between arch
nemesis like robocop and terminator
travolta versus cage and just recently
van damme took on seagal for the title
of the greatest actor that ever lived
now you hear those matchups and it might
surprise you to learn this fun fact i
love rom-coms i do i adore comedies that
tilt towards the romantic side of life
it's one thing to have a jim carrey
eddie murphy or melissa mccarthy kill me
from laughter but it's an entire other
skill to make me giggle and believe in
true love does it actually exist
sure he lives in the north pole in his
bunk mates with the easter bunny but as
long as tom hanks and hugh grant are
stumbling around town looking for the
right partner i guess i'll give finding
my person the old college tribe now you
may be saying but mark you surprisingly
single sexy beast tom hanks is america's
dad or maybe granddad by this point how
can hugh grant could be with him well
i'll remind you that yes tom hanks has
been on this show before not in person
obviously and he faced off against
denzel washington but hugh grant has
been in movies with sandra bullock who's
been featured here julia roberts
america's sweetheart and he knows
bridget who writes a diary and what
really makes this match even steven is
that neither fella is named steven and
today's fracas will only feature each
gentleman's romantic comedy resume in
one corner you have the hanks who fell
in love with an on-screen mermaid in
1984 and on his way to being a big star
found himself sleepless in seattle stuck
in a pit of money and even battling a
volcano oh and the dude looks badass on
a vespa in the other corner it's hugh
grant who rocketed to stardom seemingly
overnight earliest within the span of
nine months after a star making turn and
four weddings and a funeral but which
one of these fellas will earn our love
actually here's how we'll determine a
win
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
best characters round four believability
and then we'll do a wild card round that
might involve meg ryan versus renee
zellweger or maybe a twitch julia
roberts character is a better match for
tom and hugh i do love me some romantic
comedies and i can't put my finger on
why maybe it is the belief that we're
all just a serendipitous meat cute away
from finding that one person on earth
meant for us or maybe it's because a
rom-com provides a nice 95-minute
distraction from the inevitable truth
that we're all gonna die alone but hey
if you're gonna be lonely anyway who
better to invite over for company than
tom hanks and hugh grant the winner gets
true of the loser has to be my roommate
for all of eternity let's get it on
round one box office
you hear the term box office realize
that this round is basically won by
whichever contenders flicks make more
cash at the cineplex and next thing you
know you're penning a get well soon card
to hugh grant why because he's going up
against tom effing hanks we've seen the
guy do everything on the big screen from
captain a pirated ship to saving private
ryan to being marooned on a desert
island those are all big hits but they
ain't rom-coms
oh come on
hello
well
oh
okay
apologies to wilson he was a very good
boy and is survived by his family a
basketball and a baseball glove
well who wrote that
annoying
pissing me off actually again it's only
rom comps today but hanks still appears
to be the king 1984 splash was a hit out
of the gate earning 63 million dollars
on a minuscule budget then big happened
four years later and crushed to the tune
of 151 million dollars domestically
other big-time home runs by the guy who
once played jimmy dugan include
sleepless in seattle which brought home
228 million dollars worth of bacon and
you've got mail which earned 250 million
dollars that buys a lot of america
online hours
[Music]
now it's hugh grant's turn and he
sheepishly steps up to the plate and
wait a minute is that hugh or is that
mighty casey at the bat dude has got
some hits and got started early in his
career with the best picture nominee for
weddings and a funeral which did 243
million dollars worth of international
business and then notting hill would
surpass that to be the only rom-com on
either gent's imdb to garner over 300
million dollars 364 mil to be exact hugh
grant also played a decidedly less
charming more smarmy character in the
two bridget jones's films both of those
can journal about making over 200
million dollars around the globe so not
only is hugh grant competitive in this
round he has a chance to take a
one-to-nothing lead over tommy however
hanks can counter with some surprising
stats the terminal isn't considered one
of his or steven spielberg's best movies
but it still earned 219 million dollars
grant answers the bell once again
reminding us all that there's no hit
like a holiday smash and love actually
made 247 million dollars way back when
we were all cool with body shaming and
creepy zombie killers admitting they're
in love with their best friend's gal by
way of dimitri martin poster board we've
already listed every tom hanks rom-com
or rc's as i'll refer them heretofore
that earned over 100 million dollars
however hugh grant also has movies like
nine months sense and sensibility and
about a boy that crossed that line
easily and two weeks notice fell only
one million dollars short of joining the
200 million dollar club just a million
bucks that's couch change all told we
have a shocking upset in round one hugh
grant's rc's have earned a total of 2.3
billion dollars against hanks's total of
just over a billion and while it's true
hanks has been in far less romantic
comedies than hugh grant that makes
grants average all the more impressive
hugh grant averages 156 million dollars
every time he makes a laughing love fest
hanks's average is 131 million dollars
and as chris berman likes to say that's
why they play the games and this is why
we got us a match hugh grant takes a one
nothing lead over tom hanks and he's the
captain now and i found myself wishing i
were as lucky as he
round two tomato meter slash audience
score once again we enter a round that
seems like a shoe-in for tom hanks he's
in the toy story movies and they average
like 99.9
on a tomato meter but they're not
romantic comedies really thought him and
bo peep have a thing or did she run off
with the uh the astronaut is forkey
involved i'm not worried you shouldn't
be worried those movies do not count
today but what will in this round is
what the critics and audiences had to
say after they lined up around the block
to see tom and hugh and they really like
you both hugh grants his tomato meter
average for all of his heartfelt hahas
by the end of this show i will have come
up with a better term than rom-com is
fresh he's resting cozy at 65 percent
thanks in large part due to his
breadwinner sense and sensibility at 97
4 weddings in the dead person at 96
percent about a boy 93
and florence foster jenkins at 88
and meryl streep has entered the chat
tom hanks also has a 97 on his resume
with big reaching that high in 1988
splash is also a certified fresh hit at
91 percent but for all the roses we love
throwing the way of tom hanks and meg
ryan rightfully so their tomato meter
relationship is good 75 for sleepless in
seattle 70 for you've got male and 64
for joe versus the volcano which should
definitely be a future episode of this
show however tom hanks still has an
overall fresh average on the tomato
meter besting his opponent with a 68 per
flick score
both gents have fallen prey to
rottenness and no i'm not talking about
hugh grant's incident just before the
release of nine months come on you knew
the joke was coming and we got it out of
the way and now we can move on but
disappointing to 15 year old me is that
that movie nine months is a delight of a
film starring julian moore jeff goldblum
tom arnold joan cusack and the legend
robin williams yet it's only 26 of the
tomato meter also super low is bridget
jones the edge of reason at 27
and did you hear about the morgans to
which the critics answered yes we did
unfortunately and it landed at 12
tom hanks and cheers legend shelley long
didn't raise a glass with a money pit
which is at 50 percent and larry crown
is his only other rotten rom-com at 37
hugh grant's rotten films on the tomato
meter improved their look on the
audience score by a few points here and
there and bridget jones 2 more writing
actually made it into fresh territory
with the audience notching an even 60
however hanks will see fresh films like
joe versus the volcano break bad with
the audience garnering 54
and for some reason splash falls all the
way to 58
folks how is that possible it's got john
candy and eugene levy rewatch it and
give little ronnie howard some justice
tom hanks remains justified overall with
his audience score average it's 64
percent which tops hugh grants 60
so both of these fellows can walk into
any bar or pub in the world and never
have to pay for a drink although it's
tom hanks who's brewski might be a tad
fresher his average is higher on both
metrics which is good enough to get him
a win in round two team bosom buddies is
on the board and dies a score one to one
they're gonna hate us at the beginning
but but we'll get them in the air
you know why why
because we're gonna sell them cheap
books and legal addictive stimulants
round three best character
and now that we've seen how successful
and well-received so many of tom and
hughes films are we can dive deep into
the characters they played that made us
all believe in true love and mermaids
and a british prime minister falling in
love with his intern that'll play well
in the papers right but in a round
devoted to memorable roles it's not just
about the actors that we of course adore
it's about how wide a net they can cast
over a range of different character
types that all can play within the
romantic comedy sandbox no pressure
dudes
never mind well like i said tom hanks
fell in love with the mermaid and so
that should be a point already it helps
that said mermaid madison was played by
daryl hannah and it also helped that
director ron howard gave the then sitcom
star tom hanks a little piece of advice
don't go for the laughs just love the
girl that could have become tom hanks's
mantra for his romantic flicks going
forward never is zany as contemporary
yuck fest like a bachelor party hanks
settled into his role as a relatable
everyman in splash then repeated the
effort with some age and life weariness
in later films like you've got mail and
larry crown that could have easily
turned into sentimental overload and
sleepless in seattle given that his
character sam baldwin has recently lost
his wife to cancer and he's not sure if
he'll ever find a meaningful partner
again but this is tom effing hanks his
real middle name is jeffrey but he
changed it to effing after winning
back-to-back academy awards
i'm gonna say that's true no no no it's
true and he found the perfect middle
ground while sleepless we do feel
sympathy for sam we're clearly rooting
for him but not because he's a sad sack
it's because he really is giving his
best effort to get back on his feet oh
and he has to be a good father and
provider at the same time it's a great
performance in a movie that i totally
didn't cry at all watching last night i
was making a french onion suit from
scratch and uh like i cry at that movie
i ball it's a great film and if the
hanks is a normal joe hugh grant's go to
is that funny shy self-deprecating
charmer who can't fully express how he
feels this way or why he does until it's
almost too late that's the guy that we
fell in love with in four weddings and a
funeral the guy who swept us off our
feet in notting hill and the guy who
apparently i and no one else cared about
in nine months but throughout his career
as the rom-com has remained his bread
and butter hughes changed up how he
approaches these roles and which type of
character he wants to play by his own
admission grant was getting tired of
playing his usual rom-com type so when
bridget jones came around he happily
took the role of the guy who doesn't
deserve the girl he adopted an accent
for a more introspective attitude in
about a boy oh no no no no no you've
always had that wrong
i really am this shallow and had a
groundbreaking role as clive durham in
the indie film maurice grant reflected
on that role a few years back noting he
wasn't aware that a film would be such a
cathartic piece for gay people in or out
of the closet but since he's received
thousands of letters from real folks
letting him know that his performance
helped them feel more comfortable in
their own skin bravo sir tom hanks did
occasionally step out of his comfort
zone as well who'd he play in that
volcano movie again oh yeah joe joe
doesn't have much time left on earth so
he decides to end it all by jumping into
a volcano but the fates intervene and he
meets multiple meg ryan's and uh that
movie's nuts but it's a fun kind of nuts
he also adopted an accent to play victor
in the terminal yes and while that movie
or the dialect may be a bit sloppy or
over the top we're still pulling for
that guy and that's why hanks is such a
legend in this genre he's a dude we
think we can be and maybe the fortunes
he finds in a film could someday be ours
i encourage you all to go into a chat
room and meet some stranger and start
you know what maybe not in 2022 or ever
again but you've got mail remains a
sweet time capsule of a bygone era when
we had to leave the house to buy books
nowadays i uh hope you and your amazon
delivery person hit it off hugh grant
also has established a reliable every
man quality he can turn on effortlessly
sense and sensibility has it as does
love actually and as much as i do cattle
prod elements of that movie let's look
at the achievement of his character the
prime minister that's who he is in the
movie and it's a sea of folks and
storylines that should feel more
relevant to our own lives but his is the
one we bond with the most why because
that's hugh f and grant not only did he
apparently steal tom hanks's middle name
he just stole this round why the breadth
of character within a rom-com the depth
that his roles take us to and the
occasional risks have paid off with
better results than his opponent tom
hanks was still a badass in apollo 13
and earned his academy award nomination
for playing josh baskin in big but it's
hugh grant who gets a giant point here
and goes up 2-1
you're entitled to hate me round four
iconic moments
now we're into the money round and hugh
grant fans all over the world are on
their feet delirious with the sugar plum
visions in their head of their champion
possibly pulling off a huge upset if
huey can win this round i can call him
that right no
no he takes the match if tom hanks wins
this phase it's a tie and he'll have all
the momentum heading into the wild card
round characters are necessary critical
reviews can be encouraging and money can
buy everything in the world except
love but that's what these iconic
moments are all about every romantic
comedy has them the scenes where a first
kiss is planted or a rejection thickens
the plot or when we're in a desperate
race against time to get the astronauts
aboard apollo 13 back home safe that's
right it's not a romantic comedy but if
tom hanks dance are saying houston we
have a problem here comes robert loggia
and a giant piano to save the day come
on we've all dreamed of playing
chopsticks on a huge instrument in front
of a captive audience at fao schwartz
but seeing hanks and loja live out that
moment is for the romantic in all of us
and while it's true that loja and hank
don't end up falling for each other and
big it still counts as a special scene
as does that entire movie because we're
so swept up by the fun this kid is
having in an adult's body that we never
really stop to think about how creepy it
is that elizabeth perkins is essentially
falling in love with a little boy that's
movie magic folks the sleepover scene in
big is great as is the underwater kiss
and splash but once tom hanks teamed up
with meg ryan for a trilogy of rom-com
delights he shifted into fifth gear the
near-misses at the airport in the beach
when meg and tom catch fleeting glimpses
of each other and sleepless in seattle
the not terrible but awkward partners
they have and you've got mail and
sleepless in seattle hey here's a
question would you rather marry meg's
love interest from sleepless bill
pullman he's a nice guy but he's boring
his sin and wouldn't know how to deliver
a joke if fedex gave him the box and he
has every allergy under the sun
today i consider myself the luckiest
or would you marry greg kinnear from
you've got mail
sort of a nice guy but a gigantic ego
with a wandering eye
jeffersonian purity that was nice thank
you thank you that sounded good are you
taping this quick sidebar i love their
breakup scene halfway through you've got
mail they both know it's time they rip
the band-aid off and then enjoy a drink
laughing about it ah breaking up the
mark ellis way with giggles and alcohol
you don't love me
okay back to this happy stuff hank's
vision of his past wife and sleepless
feel so real and visceral regardless of
whether the audience has experienced a
similar loss and his interactions with
his well-intentioned son jonah cement
him as a dad we all want to find a
suitable partner the climax of the
empire state building is more romantic
the ending meetup if you've got mail is
more based in reality and both make us
feel like that's gonna happen to us as
soon as we leave the theater and i'm
still waiting i'll keep you posted
meanwhile hugh grant was something of a
straight man to the zaniness in nine
months where tom arnold and robin
williams excelled with the over-the-top
giggles but he's right at home playing
the stuffy not ready to grow up guy in
that flick or as the awe shucks good
dude in sense and sensibility as he
chose more diverse roles we got to see
some great ass holiness in bridget jones
diary like the epic fight he has with
colin firth or even when he realizes
just how shallow he is and how he out
kicked his coverage with rachel in about
a boy but grant can always return to his
go-to move the i can't even stumble
these beautiful words out of my charming
mouth because i'm just so smitten play
witness it in notting hill and it even
rubs off on movie star julia roberts in
her legendary i'm just a girl speech i'm
also just a girl
standing in front of a boy but grant
typifies everything that we love about
him as well as how we can make him a
caricature in four weddings in the
casket he's not exactly david cassidy
smooth but he manages to eventually have
the words i think i love you warble out
of his throat and he's very lucky andy
mcdowell was in a very patient mood that
day the dance sequence in love actually
is a winner and it's even more enjoyable
in retrospect with the knowledge that
hugh grant hated doing it and did not
want any part of it similarly tom hanks
riding around in a vespa for two hours
makes us just as uncomfortable as hugh
in those dancing shoes but for all the
leading man pizzazz that grant certainly
has the outlandish premises of dating a
mermaid to a volcano blast to a wish
granting fortune teller to meeting
justin the nick of time at the empire
state building lent so many moments to
them and to us and to pull all that off
without losing your audience in the
process there's really only gonna be one
guy that can do that jean-claude van
damme he wasn't available so tom hanks
stepped in and knocked them all out of
the stadium he takes round four and
we're tied at two to two which means
today's match will be settled by the
wild card round legacy both hugh grants
and tom hanks's legacy are as secure as
their bank accounts i hope but which
rom-com star has had more of an impact
on cinema this particular genre and us
as an audience well the romantic in me
is asking why can't we just say they're
both great and end in a tie as the
credits roll to some sappy dance number
but that ain't how we do things on this
show like love versus is a battlefield
and like the great romantic comedy
highlander there can be only one tom
hanks's legacy will be much more than
just the rom-com guy but you can't tell
the story of the hangs without
mentioning how great those films are and
how wonderful he is inside of their
stories the reason he became america's
favorite leading man even though he lost
to denzel washington on the popular show
versus it's because he appeals to all of
us his diverse resume is testament to
that claim us kids wanted to go see
turner and hooch mom wanted to see
bonfire the vanities and my dad loved
the money pit mainly because shelley
long was my mom's doppelganger but all
of those different roles made the family
want to go see movies like sleepless in
seattle and you've got mail my mom is
actually probably on her elliptical
machine right now watching one of those
tom hanks excels as a guy in completely
ridiculous premises because he's
grounded and that allows the action to
remain fantastical his dr langdon and
those da vinci code films might have
some questions about land bound merfolk
or how exactly one could survive
multiple volcano blasts but we don't
care why because we know him and it's
our ability to relate to him as our
friend lover neighbor as us that we
trust in what he's doing that's tom
hanks on the movie poster but once those
lights go down it's ourselves that we're
watching on the big screen meanwhile
hugh grant is a guy that we're rooting
for but more importantly we want to see
how it's going to play out sure we can
see ourselves in him at times and we
prefer that he wins in the end but more
than anything we're curious as to how
the annie mcdowells julia roberts and
drew barrymores of the world are going
to react to him it's as if we're
scientists testing love potions in
cinematic form does the bumbling aw
shucks work on andy yes on renee no so
we add a pinch of ego and a dash of
smarm that's better but now we just need
pure uncut normalcy and we'll pair that
with a julia roberts success we might
mock him for his inability to get any
thought out without indulging us with
way too many words and quirks but that
quality is also what is so endearing
about him he's good looking but his hair
is always frazzled he seems slightly out
of breath and he's just so desperate to
come off his swap and he never does does
that remind you of anyone it should
because that's all of us even your
occasional prime minister when he comes
to his intern's house on christmas to
announce his feelings the power dynamic
might be too much for us to take if it
was anyone else but hugh's disarming
gentlemanly self-deprecating quality
makes it work much like when tom hanks
is still grieving widower fields a call
on the spot from dr marsha fieldstone
and although his instinct is to recoil
he can't help but open up his feelings
and be heartbreakingly honest neither
actor will ever be pigeonholed as just a
romantic comedy lead hanks is an all-out
movie star and grant has proved his
versatility time and time again as
recently as the hbo series the undoing
which does play out as a rom-com for
about seven minutes and then the
laughter dies and so do people but he's
great in it i can't make this call all
of my own so i'm gonna rely on the list
of some of the world's most prestigious
publications according to vanity fair
you've got mail is the second best
rom-com ever bridget jones's diary is
fourth notting hill is seven and
sleepless in russell wilson's backyard
is number ten i bet russ goes to another
team this offseason thus dating this
episode just as much as a movie about a
rival bookstore owner using aol chat
meanwhile elle magazine has you've got
mail at three four weddings at five
sleepless in pearl jam's basement at
eight and notting hill at 10. i think
we're right back to where we started so
while tom hanks and meg ryan might be
the greatest couple in rom-com history
hugh grant's resume features more films
with more leading ladies hanks's movies
are big sells because of him and the
crazy events that put him in an odd
romantic predicament but hugh grant can
break good or bad and can surprise us
with who his next on-screen romantic
encounter might be and for that i'm
giving him the win in this round and
thus the match i'm not going to be an
american citizen after this anymore am i
congratulations hugh grant wins
what is this
may i ask who you are well done bud and
keep that couch in your london flat open
because tom hanks isn't gonna stand for
this he's an all-time great multi-oscar
winner yet the hanks is 0-2 in his
career on this show his next fight
should be against like i don't know all
the expendables and he can just mow them
down one by one i love the guy's movies
but in my defense he's got eight
rom-coms to his credit grant has roughly
doubled that my mother has trouble
remembering my name
so hugh grant gets the nod and a nail
biter that even surprised your host and
i wrote the script yesterday but now
it's your turn fearless viewer vote for
your take by hitting me up on social
media at mark ellis live and defend your
choice like you would your true love
until next time this is versus i'm your
host mark ellis and i'm just a boy
standing in front of a girl who has no
idea that i'm actually a 12 year old
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you